so we have to have a conversation about
something not so good that's happening
on the i guess i would call it the
online left media
in the online left media world which is
a level of pettiness
that at this point should concern every
single one of us that actually wants to
get some things done and make some
progress
and maybe not see democrats completely
crushed in the november midterm
elections
uh and what i'm talking about is a very
toxic subculture that's taking place
among many in the audience of shows like
mine
uh in which there is just a completely
counterproductive
self-destructive
argumentation happening constantly about
which show is better
who's a shill
this show's bad that shows bad pacman's
terrible this that the other thing and
the reason that i sort of came across
this
is a couple people sent me over the not
over the weekend over the last few days
i was getting back from my trip
um
some links to some of subreddit
discussions and discord discussions
where my name comes up in the context of
am i one of the good guys or am i one of
the bad guys why am i terrible and you
can find lots of reasons why i'm
terrible including i'm terrible because
my uh youtube titles are uh click bait
or because i'm not doing enough deep
foreign policy analysis
or because you know i have a bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad or whatever and
this stuff is all happening supposedly
among people on the left who share like
95
of the same goals
so let's just sort of like start at the
middle and work our way out right so so
like let's take the criticism
my show is bad
because i do this type of show and not
that type of show i don't do deep
foreign policy analysis listen
um every show has a different niche and
a different goal
the point of this show is to be
a popularizer of being informed
of thinking about how political choices
impact the world we live in
to be a a show that inspires people to
actually at minimum vote if not do more
which nearly half the country doesn't do
and to warn people about the horrifying
reality of the scourge
that is right-wing extremism and
reactionary politics and
authoritarianism and to make sure
everybody remembers this is not a both
side situation in the united states we
really have one side that is completely
out of their mind and another side
that's just not quite left enough for me
and those are two very different things
we talk to interesting smart people from
different fields to expose people in the
audience to the fact that all these
different fields exist and if one of
them piques your interest then you can
do deep dives into that find books five
find podcasts to deep dive into any
particular topic that interests you
create a like-minded a community of
like-minded people to come together
through the show itself and our discord
and our subreddit and all these
different things
and then you can say well i really care
about education so in addition to
listening to the pacman podcast i'll
listen to podcasts about education for
example or i care about climate change
so i'll add some climate youtubers
uh science climatologist youtubers to my
subscriptions or whatever and uh
that is really the point of this
particular show so yes this is not a
show that is exclusively long form
foreign policy analysis
that doesn't mean that this show is any
better or any worse than a different
show now yes different shows have
different levels of production quality
different shows have different levels of
you you know experience for the host or
whatever the case may be
but this sniping thing that i see so
many people in my audience and in other
audiences engage in about oh sam cedar's
bad because of his view on this one
issue or tyt is good better than pac-man
because of this or pac-man shows
that this is extraordinarily petty and
self-destructive and the right doesn't
do this
the right does a lot of horrible things
which we criticize but the right just
looks at
is are these people basically helping
our movement or are they basically
hurting our movement
is this someone who we mostly agree with
and that's kind of the starting point
and unfortunately i continue to worry
that this level of pettiness and sniping
on the left is going to be very very bad
for the movement apply the analogy to
books right i don't read political
memoirs i didn't read you know uh
obama's book
i didn't read the kushner book i didn't
read hillary's book
i just have other things i prefer to
read
it doesn't mean that as a genre the
political memoir is bad i mean some are
bad some are poorly written it's a niche
and there's a need for it and that's
great but it would be weird for me to
say well i think narrative non-fiction
is better than political memoirs how do
you even compare those things and so
let's all take a step back
let's understand
who is generally advocating for the
right things the things that we believe
in the things that will improve the
country and the world in which we which
we live
and let's not inflict
this kind of circular firing squad of
self-inflicted damage it's just very bad
and pettiness is really the best way
that i can describe it let me know what
you think
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack the keto friendly granola bars and
nut and seed bars i keep these stocked
in my pantry all the time the texture is
great the sweet gooey goodness is
fantastic but each bar has only one gram
of sugar or less just two to three net
carbs and under 150 calories my favorite
lately has been sea salt dark chocolate
people know about my love affair with
dark chocolate but you can also get
other flavors like caramel sea salt
peanut butter dark chocolate and others
then you've got the monk pack granola
bars in flavors like coconut cocoa chip
blueberry almond and honey nut i don't
do keto myself but they are a great
on-the-go snack if you love something
sweet and delicious but without the
sugar which is what i'm going for they
just hit the spot and if you don't love
monk pack as much as i do they'll refund
all of your money just email them my
audience gets 20 off your first purchase
at monkpack.com
when you use the coupon code pacman at
checkout the link is down below